tout autour de sa table en exemple
concret c'est en 2007 vincent mcdoom a
été aussi visé je crois dans un clip de
rap en appel à la mort contre c'est un
jeune rappeur en 2007 qui s'appelle
crise qui a chanté une chanson quand il
m'a vu à la télé et lui pensait s'était
pas représentatifs de ceux connus y
penser qu'un homme doit être et il a
demandé dans une chanson qui s'appelle
tout simplement mcdoom dead où il a cité
mon nom d'un gala où il a demandé de me
tuer et en fait j'ai eu la possibilité
de confronter ces jeunes hommes là et je
lui ai mais mis face à sa responsabilité
qu'il a nié en fait
en fait grâce à sébastien cauet et ce
garçon là tout de suite après l'émission
en fait il a dû se rende compte à 100
maisons de disques universal vous avez
attaqué banon exactement comme un pascal
moi je crois que c'est important de
faire la publicité pour cette personne
je lui ai déjà mis devant le fait
accompli et tout le public en a vu le
vif les français ont vu ça pour moi
c'était déjà
alors oui pour pascal praud le parquet a
ouvert une enquête
ces deux pas de là malheureusement il la
justice est très clémente quand il
s'agit de chansons et à un exemple
encore plus récent nick conrad qui
disait je rentre dans les crèches je tue
des bébés blanc attrapé l'éviter pendent
et leurs parents dans un clip mais
savait ce qu'il a il a eu comme il a il
a eu cinq mille euros d'amendé avec
sursis et 1000 euros de dommages et
intérêts aux associations qui avaient
porté plainte moi je tourne toi c'est
plus sympa
qui auront je trouve cela scandaleux on
peut penser que c'est la liberté des
crassiers les dans la chanson